[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning it's
that time again time to bring you some
of the stories that are the talk of the
table this morning and gail king is
going first
okay i'd love to mine's about a mom she
brought out all her mama bear
this happened in lake jackson texas at
south of houston
she pulled off a football move to
protect her children now before you look
at it watch the little stutter steps she
does
it's a heck of a tackle no i love it i
hope we show it again tackling a man
in the middle of the street last month
look at the stutter step i'm gonna get
you
i mean why didn't she textbook why did
she do that the suspect is accused of
peeping into the bedroom window of her
15-year-old daughter what
they held the suspect until the officers
caught up pena says this my kids are my
life
i'm just making sure i protect them
pretty much the police chief now wants
to meet with her
and commend her he said he might even
send her a job application
so one of the cops said it's not very
often that we have somebody who steps in
and does what you did that she said the
cop fist bumped her and said i hear the
texans
are looking for a new linebacker i just
i just
i don't think it's a good look in jail
for the guy that got tackled either oh
we saw you on tv
yeah do sell me go fill us up